bruno de russky bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on l'a vu à
la pologne il fait face à une nouvelle
crise migratoire pour pour commencer les
principales explications de cette
nouvelle arrivée
quelles sont elles
alors bon sur le long terme c'est le
fait évidemment que la ville au riche y
est sous la pression globalement de
l'union européenne est beaucoup plus
particulièrement de la pologne mais
aussi de la lituanie qu'on a un peu
tendance à oublier dans ce dans ce
dossier générale en europe donc ça c'est
évidemment la vraie raison bon il est il
est clair que la biélorussie le
président loukachenko en particulier
venant quelques sans faire une pression
sur la pologne en utilisant les migrants
qui auparavant on pouvait avoir tendance
à transiter par la biélorussie merlot de
l'union européenne mais en nombre
beaucoup moins important que maintenant
et jusque là il entre guillemets faisait
le boulot c'est-à-dire qu'il bloquait
ses migrants en biélorussie aujourd'hui
oui évidemment il a tendance à augmenter
le nombre si je peux dire est au
contraire les poussées pour en quelque
sorte
délégitimer la pologne et faire pression
auprès d'elle pour qu'elle cesse sa
politique
de 2,2 de champion et de menaces à
l'égard de minsk que ça c'est évidemment
la raison
de cette crise
ben on verra évidemment
comment les choses vont se concevant
fonctionner mais comme par ailleurs
effectivement la pologne a de très
nombreuses raisons de de tensions avec
ses partenaires entre guillemets ou pas
de l'union européenne pour lui il se
retrouve en fait quelqu'un quelque part
entre deux feux d'un côté misé que de
l'autre côté bruxelles est évidemment
dans ce contexte là le président
biélorusse ya essaie de pousser varsovie
vers un compromis en utilisant la
manière forte voilà oui parce qu'il est
effectivement il ya d'un côté ce fut une
l'iran que doivent gérer les polonais et
puis il ya varsovie a été condamné une
nouvelle fois hier par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour la
réforme de son système judiciaire
ces tensions entre la pologne l'union
européenne quel impact elle ont
justement sur cette question la gestion
des flux migratoires
justement tu es c'est tout le problème
on on remarque que depuis le début de
cette tension on laisse un peu varsovie
seul d'ailleurs je faisais remarquer au
on laisse voir se vit seul et en même
temps on parle beaucoup de la beaucoup
plus à pour l'one que la lituanie alors
que la situation à la frontière
lituanienne est comparable mais la
lituanie n'est pas dans le viseur si je
peux dire le brussels donc cesser ces
petites un point sur lequel il faut
aussi montrer qu'un double un double
double standard entre les contres deux
pays membres de l'union européenne mais
bien sûr
on voit cette occasion que varsovie ne
bénéficient pas je n'ai rien de toute la
sympathie entre guillemets ou pas de ses
partenaires de l'union européenne à
cause des autres tensions qui qui qui
qui se sont développées entre varsovie
et bruxelles on est dans une situation
évidemment extrêmement complexe puisque
les dossiers ce qui veut dire
s'accumulent les uns contradictoire avec
les autres
et je ne sais pas combien de temps
évidemment barre celui peuvent pas
pouvoir continuer à mener cette double
politique c'est à dire une politique
visant musc d'un côté tout en ayant une
politique qui indispose pour le moins
qu'on puisse dire bruxelles parce qu'il
ya une autre décision qui concerne
varsovie là encore attendues aujourd'hui
par la cour de justice européenne il
s'agit de cette discorde autour de la
mine de charbon de turreau avec la
république tchèque expliquez-nous qui
était là le noeud du problème alors le
noeud du problème c'est une mine qui
qui polluent beaucoup la région alors
évidemment on a tendance à ne voir
qu'une partie du problème parce que si
on regarde bien les choses il y a des
mines de lignite du contenu siècle la
frontière dont personne ne parle mais il
n'en reste pas moins que cette mine du
côté polonais de la frontière risque de
polluer très largement l'environnement
régional pas seulement polonais et que
la pologne a fait une erreur il ya
didier à la lampe à nos comptes de
l'année puisqu'elle a décidé qu'elle
prendrait la décision seul alors même
qu'elle
jusque là elle négocier avec les les
négociations ont repris maintenant on
sera évidemment ce qu'elles vont donner
mais évidemment au milieu de tout ça
vous avez à peu près 80 mille ouvriers
employés polonais qui vivent de cette
mine directement ou indirectement
vous avez 5 % de la production d'énergie
électrique polonaise qui vient de cette
mine
donc évidemment fermé la mine ce qui
existe maintenant l'union européenne à
la demande de prague tout au moins
officiellement la demande de prague mais
a évidemment une politique générale de
l'union européenne sur le charbon ou
plutôt contre le charbon qui indispose
les polonais dans la mesure où pour la
pologne le charbon c'est aussi
l'indépendance énergétique et puis c'est
même symbole national le cerveau le
jargon c'est depuis depuis deux siècles
la grande richesse nationale et les
mineurs un peu le symbole un symbole de
la de la classe ouvrière et de et du
travail polonais c est la pologne
condamné à une amende journalière
particulièrement exceptionnelle 1 sur ce
dossier par l'union européenne oui bien
sûr bien sûr alors bon les négociations
entre varsovie et prague ont repris et
finalement si elles aboutissent tout
cela évidemment va être modifiée mais
évidemment pour le moment nous sommes
dans un état de pression maximum de
bruxelles on remarquera néanmoins que la
protestation
vient de de la république tchèque que
l'allemagne n'a pas osé
intervenir sur ce dossier directement
auprès du tribunal européen et donc bon
on en voit que berlin est en train de se
poser des questions sur
cher de la fragilité de la pologne de
poste quand ancienne mais sur la
nécessité quand même de garder ce
partenaire pour nos vins qui est
stratégique pour l'allemagne et pour
l'économie et l'allemagne qui elle aussi
a des mines de charbon donc on peut
effectivement s'interroger sur un deux
poids deux mesures ou encore bien sûr il
ya deux poids deux mesures au niveau du
cerveau il ya deux poids deux mesures
aussi au niveau de la cour
constitutionnelle parce que la cour
constitutionnelle allemande avait aussi
auparavant montré que leur a décidé que
le droit allemand était supérieur au
droit européen ce qui n'avait pas
provoquer de scandale aussi
aussi des rues lent que maintenant donc
effectivement on a un deux poids deux
mesures
j'irai toute l'union européenne
fonctionne sur des rapports de force qui
visons ont toujours existé sauf
qu'aujourd'hui c'est manifeste de façon
beaucoup plus clairement où on voit que
chaque état membre fonctionne un peu en
fonction de la force qu'il a et en
fonction de ses intérêts et en même
temps il n'y a pas une cohésion
comme le petit qui correspondent
exactement
aux discours sur 10 ans la pacification
que l'union européenne serait censé
apporter dans les rapports entre états
européens merci bruits des bruits coup
voilà merci à bruno bruschi pour cet
éclairage sur rt france ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes politologue maître de
conférences à l'inalco